few two corrections i want to make to
the video on the sodium potassium pump
one very minor one and i don't think it
would trip too many of you guys up but
near the end of the video as we learned
we have potassium getting pumped into
the cell by the sodium potassium pump
let me draw the membrane it'll actually
be useful in the more significant
correction i'd like to make
i'd like to make so let me draw a cell
membrane a cross section of a cell
membrane and let me draw the sodium
potassium pump right here
the sodium potassium pump and we saw it
pumps out three sodiums for every two
potassiums that it pumps in so it might
look some well it definitely doesn't
look like that but it gives us the idea
and we're pumping we're pumping
potassium ions in
so k plus
k plus and we're pumping sodium ions out
and that's what the whole point of that
video was when this thing changes shape
with atp it pump it pumps out the sodium
the sodium ions out now the minor
correction i want to make and i don't
think it would have tripped you up too
much is near the end of that video i
drew the potassium ions and i wrote a k
plus but a few times near the end of the
video i referred to them as sodium ions
and i don't want that to confuse you at
all it is potassium ions that are
getting pumped in
two potassium ions get pumped in for
every three sodium ions that get pumped
out so i don't want you know even though
i drew k plus sometimes i said sodium by
accident don't want that to confuse you
that is the minor error the more
significant error is that i said that
the main reason that we had this
potential difference why it is more
positive on the outside
why
it is more positive on the outside
than the inside so this is less positive
i said that the main reason was because
of this ratio we're pumping out three
sodium ions for every two potassium ions
that we pump in and i just got a very
nice letter from a professor of
physiology stephen baylor at university
of pennsylvania and he wrote a very
interesting email and it corrects me and
it's a very interesting well it's an
interesting thing to think about in
general so here's what he wrote and
let's think about what he's saying he
says here at penn medical school we have
a nice teaching program that stimulates
the ion fluxes across a generic cell so
the ion flux is just the movement of the
ions across the membrane
including that due to the sodium
potassium pump and that which arises
from the resting permeabilities of the
membrane so the resting permeability is
how easy it is for these ions to go
through to go through the membrane we'll
talk more about that in a second
and the resting permeabilities of the
membrane to sodium potassium chlorate
chloride etc
our option one option our program gives
students
is to change the pump stoichiometry from
three to two so when he's talking about
pump stoichiometry from three to two
he's just talking about they're changing
the ratio so they change it from three
to two to two to two so what that means
is they have a simulation program that
says well what if the sodium potassium
pump instead of pumping three sodiums
out for every two potassium it pumps in
what if it was even what if it was two
sodiums and two potassiums and based on
my explanation of why we have this
potential difference that should not
lead to a potential difference if the
main reason was the stoichiometry the
ratio of sodium being pumped out to
potassium being pumped in but he goes on
to say so you could they could change it
to two to two in the simulation as a
result of this maneuver the potential
the membrane potential changes from its
normal value of about negative 80
millivolts and they measure that they
take they take the voltage here minus
the voltage there so that you get a
negative number this is more positive
it's a larger number so it changes from
negative 80 millivolts to about negative
78 millivolts so what he's saying is if
you change this from three and two three
sodiums for every two potassium that get
pumped in if you change that to two to
two it actually doesn't change the
potential that much you still have a
more a more positive environment outside
than you have inside so that's that
leads to the question then why
do we have the potential if this if the
stoichiometry of this ratio is not the
main cause and then so it says it it
changes a little bit it becomes a little
bit let the potential difference becomes
a little bit less the swell the cell
swells a few percentage and then
everything stabilizes so then he goes on
to write
so while it is true that the normal
stoichiometry of the pump does have a
slight negative a slight negative
influence on the membrane potential
that's just the membrane potential the
voltage across the membrane the
imbalance in the pump stoichiometry is
not the main reason for the large
negative membrane potential of the cell
rather the main let me underline this
the main reason is the concentration
gradients established by the pump
in combination with the fact that the
resting cell membrane is highly
permeable to potassium and only slightly
permeable to sodium so we said and we
when we in the last video or the first
video on the sodium potassium pump we
said that there were channels there were
channels that the sodium could go
through
that the sodium could go through and
there's also channels that the potassium
could go through
and that the potassium could go through
that the potassium could go through and
now what he's saying is that the main
cause of the potential difference isn't
this ratio it's the fact that
this the membrane is highly
highly permeable to potassium so this is
very permeable
potassium can get out if it wants to
much easier than it is for sodium
to get in so what that happens even if
this was a two to two ratio it's
actually a three to two but even if this
was a two to two ratio
even though this environment is more
positive you're just more likely to have
potassium ions down here bump in just
the right way to get across and get to
the other side go against its chemical
gradient right because you have a higher
concentration of potassium here then
over here so you're more likely to have
a potassium bump in just the right way
to get through this channel and get out
then you are to have a sodium be able to
go the opposite direction and that's
what makes this environment so you have
more potassium coming outside because of
this permeability then sodium coming
inside and that is what causes or that's
the main cause of the potential
difference between the outside and the
inside
and so thank you stephen baler for that
correction very interesting